diese mysteriöse anomalie bereitet
forschenden weltweit kopfzerbrechen die
rede ist von dem auffälligen signal
überschuss im dunkle materie den sektor
xenon 1c bereits im sommer diesen jahres
2020 hatte die xenon kollaboration
diesen rätselhaften punkt bekannt
gegeben
jetzt wurde intensiv geforscht und das
ergebnis ist na ja es sind ergebnisse
denn es ist weiterhin absolut mysteriös
was da gefunden wurde handelt sich sich
etwa um die dunkle materie um völlig
neuartige teilchen oder neue
physikalische gesetzmäßigkeiten
ich stelle hier die verschiedenen
hypothesen vor bei der die eine
rätselhafte ist als die andere klicks
und wirtschaft hier gibt es drei mal pro
woche spannende science - abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen der signal überschuss
wirklich super rätselhaft und ist
bislang von den fachleuten weltweit
nicht wirklich einzuordnen handelt es
sich um einen wink der physik um
komplett neuartigen teilchen von denen
bislang niemand eine auch nur eine leise
ahnung hatte wir hatten ja darüber
berichtet zwischen wbo 2017 und februar
2018 kamen überraschend vielen teilchen
zusammenstößen mit elektronen der 3,2
tonnen schwere der tecdoc sehen und 1c
im italienischen untergrund labor sang
grasso hatte einen deutlichen signal
überschuss registriert damals nämlich
meldete das forschungsteam einen
überraschenden überschuss von 53
ereignissen über die erwarteten 232
ereignisse und diese zusätzlichen
lichtsignale sorgen seit juni diesen
jahres für extreme aufregung der xenon 1
tc sektor ist tatsächlich ein meister
beim registrieren solcher lichtblitze
kurze erklärung es handelt sich um einen
tank der mit flüssigem zenon gefüllt ist
und von photo detektoren umringt ist
falls ein sogenanntes wiki interactive
messeparty gekürzt auf ein xenon atom
trifft sollte dieses dann überschüssige
energie in form eines lichtblitze aus
senden und die wilms gelten als
favorisierte kandidatin für dunkle
materie teilchen wie ihr name schon
verrät handelt es sich um schwach
wechsel wirkende massereiche teilchen
wir haben hier bei pixum sinnflut schon
öfter darüber berichtet von 2016 bis
den hat extrem 91 t den auftrag die
sogenannten ums aufzuspüren man geht
davon aus dass sie auch als schwächlinge
bezeichneten partikel eine große masse
haben
elektrisch neutral sind und eben nur in
geringem umfang mit anderen teilchen
wechselwirken doch diese dunkle materie
teilchen sind bislang nur hypothetisch
und wurden einzig und allein
vorhergesagt um das dunkle materie
problem zu verstehen doch bislang konnte
keines der zahlreichen experimente
weltweit hinweise auf die existenz der
wind liefern
handelt es sich bei dem auffälligen
signal überschuss im dunklen materie
detektor exelon 110 nun also endlich um
die mysteriöse dunkle materie
das wäre dann wirklich hundertprozentige
sensation das große problem aber ist die
rätselhafte signale passen nicht zu den
signalen die die fachleute von rihms
erwarten würden denn die daten
offenbaren dass die auslösenden teilchen
nicht den kern sondern vor allem die
elektronen decks den as rom getroffen
haben ein weiteres indiz dass gegen die
wilms spricht ist dass jede dieser
koalition laut der messung eine zu
geringe energie auf die atome übertragen
hat konkret handelt es sich um wenige
kilo elektronenvolt deutlich zu wenig
für die 136 vorstellungen der szene und
kollaboration hatten bereits im juni
klargestellt dass noch viele fragen
offen sind dennoch waren auch sie mit
möglichen interpretationen ihrer
ergebnisse herausgerückt für
aufmerksamkeit sorgte vor allem der
gedanke das ist die völlig neuartige
elementarteilchen anderen könnte
möglicherweise könnten es die so
genannten aktionen gewesen sein die die
elektronen im tank vom 10 01 de
getroffen haben auch diese ultraleichten
partikel werden von manchen fachleuten
als mögliche erklärung für die dunkle
materie gehandelt wenn dies belegt
werden würde wäre das sicher nicht
weniger wert als ein nobelpreis denn
diese aktion wurden in der theorie
vorhergesagt um ungereimtheiten
bezüglich der starken kernkraft zu
erklären warum wirkt die starke
kernkraft auf antimaterie und materie
gleich doch nicht nur das aktionen
könnten mit ihren speziellen
eigenschaften auch die urheber der
dunklen materie seien bisher konnten sie
aber noch nie nachgewiesen werden klar
ist ein direkter beleg dafür dass aktion
existieren wäre spektakulär denn das
wäre endlich die bestätigung für
theorien in der physik die schon seit
jahrzehnten angenommen werden auch
unsere annahmen zu den zusammen
um der dinge in dieser welt würden damit
bestätigt der mysteriöse signal
überschuss im italienischen untergrund
experiment wäre zwar kein direkter beleg
für die dunkle materie
doch ein starker hinweis darauf dass
dieser teilchen typ häufiger um
universum vorkommt als bisher gedacht
verschiedene forschungsteams haben sich
diesem super spannenden rätsel des
auffälligen signal überschusses jetzt
angenommen
und jetzt sechs fachartikel zu diesem
thema veröffentlicht mit dabei auch die
x-te wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler und all diese hypothesen
sind grundverschieden auch hier spielen
aktionen wieder eine rolle aber auch die
exotischen neutrinos um die
leichtgewichtigen varianten der vips
sind mit dem spiel eine annahme sind
also die aktion den hypothetischen
teilchen die als leichtgewichtiger
kandidat für die dunkle materie teilchen
gelten doch klar ist auch die so
genannten dunklen aktionen haben eine zu
geringe masse um die rätselhafte signale
erklären zu können doch manche
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
gehen von einer anderen ebenfalls
hypothetischen variante der aktionen aus
diese könnten in der sonne und anderen
sternen entstehen dazu sagt elena april
sie selbst an der arbeit mit dem 10 und
110 hektar beteiligt ist solche solaren
aktionen hätten energien im kilo
elektronenvolt bereich und könnten diese
an die detektor atome übertragen haben
doch hier gibt es ein problem denn wenn
solche aktionen tatsächlich existieren
müssten sie sterne und vor allem deren
thermisches verhalten auf eine art und
weise beeinflussen wie sie den
bisherigen astrophysikalischen
beobachtungen widersprechen
ein japanisches forschungsteam hat
dieses dilemma genauer ins visier
genommen nach dem modell der forschen
könnte es solare aktionen dennoch
durchaus geben diese würden allerdings
anders als bislang angenommen mit den
photonen von sonne und anderen sternen
interagieren die interaktion der
hypothetisch vorausgesagten partikel mit
den photonen wäre demnach zufolge
deutlich weniger stark diese hypothese
des japanischen forschungsteams wäre
demnach also eine mögliche erklärung für
den rätselhaften signal überschuss
fachleute vom max planck institut für
kernphysik dagegen vermuten eine andere
ursache für das xenon 1d signal auf der
webseite heißt es der kürzlich vom 10 01
die experimente richtete überschuss an
elektronen rückstoß ereignissen könnte
als anzeichen für ein beträchtlich
so genanntes übergangs magnetisches
moment solarer neutrinos interpretiert
werden dass deutsche forschungsteam
sieht also die sonne und nicht die
dunkle materie als eine mögliche
erklärung für den signal überschuss
demnach könnten sich solaren neutrinos
in eine neuartige neutrino sorte
umgewandelt haben die so bislang noch
nicht im standardmodell der physik
enthalten ist und zwar hervorgerufen
durch die wechselwirkung mit anderen
neutrinos oder anderen teilchen wie dem
higgs boson diese neuartige neutrino
sorgte könnte dann genügend masse
aufweisen um das gemessene drei kilo
elektronenvolt signal hervorzurufen auch
die physikerinnen und physiker der xenon
kollaboration halten neutrinos als
ursache für wahrscheinlich sie sind der
ansicht dass diese neutrinos ein
größeres magnetisches moment haben
müssten als das standardmodell der
teilchenphysik bislang annimmt diese
hypothese um diese neuartigen neutrinos
halten die fachleute laut der eigenen
berechnungen als relativ wahrscheinlich
demnach liegt diese mit einem sigma von
3,2 was die wahrscheinlich an gegen nur
knapp hinter der hypothese mit den
solaren aktionen ein forschungsteam aus
den usa und auch andere fachleute halten
weiterhin an der dunkle materie als
urheber für das rätselhafte signal fest
der us-wissenschaftler bartosch fornahl
ist von beschleunigter dunkle materie
überzeugt demnach könnten die
lichtblitze die mithilfe von zeman 1c
aufgespürt worden von teilchen der
dunklen materie stammen durch die
gegenseitige animation benachbarter
teilchen könnten diese teilchen der
dunklen materie
einen zusätzlichen schub bekommen haben
der begriff an die relation kommt aus
dem lateinischen bedeutet so viel wie
zunichte machen dazu schreibt das os
forschungsteam
dann könnte ein strom beschleunigter
dunkler materie von den animationen im
galaktischen zentrum oder dem halo
ausgehen fest steht nur eine sache
das rätsel um die signale bleibt in alle
möglichen erklärungen sind bislang nur
hypothesen belege gibt es keine
weder für die angedachten teilchen noch
für die möglichen prozessen fachleute
versprechen sich viel von dem nun
anstehenden messungen mit hilfe des
deutlich größeren detektors xenon n t
denn die daten die bislang analysiert
wurden stammen alle aus der letzten
messperiode funktionen 1 t die bis ins
jahr 2018 reichte doch der neue detektor
zenon nt wird deutlich größer und damit
empfindlicher sein so
hoffen forschende auf weitere
erkenntnisse um den ursprung des
rätselhaften signals ein für alle mal zu
klären
teilchen der dunklen materie mit 99,7
sicherheit gefunden physik revolution
also hier anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren da geht es um den stand aus
dem sommer diesen jahres 2020 bis dann
bleibt dran anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren nicht vergessen klicks um
salz in future